by the way I just heard on the wrap-up
show papa fooi has some small desire to
throw another first pitch what yes what
I said what it's like what I can't
imagine why he'd want to revisit the
single most humiliating moment in his
life he thinks if he goes out and throws
another pitch it'll make this one go
away right this one is never going away
by the way I don't think that Robin but
a lot of people around me you're trying
to convince me of that because they want
to see me make a fool of myself
there's no upside because Gary if you
even throw a perfect pitch they're still
gonna go but look at his first time he
did it I had that thought for like a
half a second on the wrap-up show then I
was over it in ten minutes but the guys
on the show were like no imagine the
Redemption you go out there you do it I
go it's just another reason for the show
the first place you know what were you
thinking when you were kind of
contemplating throwing the first pitch
were you having a fantasy that you'd go
out there and throw a great pitch and
all would be forgiven I still know I
could do better but yeah I don't want to
get into the I don't want I don't want
to even go down that road anymore if you
want to consider the second time trying
it he did do it again on Jimmy Kimmel's
television show he hits a woman in the
audience with the ball in the head I did
it in high heels on the Jimmy Kimmel
show and had no problem putting it right
in Jimmy's glove practice I don't throw
balls I don't do anything
Gary you were really mad at Jimmy Kimmel
for making you do that right he kind of
put you on why did you hit him not that
woman ten years later news anchors are
still goofing on Gary I know they're
never gonna give that up
anchor Raul Martinez showed tape of
himself throwing out the first pitch
another anchor then mentioned Gary's
pitch so even when these guys are just
talking about something completely other
than Gary Gary makes his way in look at
the off-speed right oh he followed the
howard stern show baba booey had one of
the greatest four images ever a two or
three hops before it got to them thanks
cool that was just recently well not
only was it two or three hops it went
away from the home plate it it trailed
off
I meant to do that a football player
named Denard Robinson botched his first
pitch at news anchor reference Baba
Booey when discussing the pitch it's
amazing how hard that is to do one bad
step there and all of a sudden your Baba
Booey Gary hates that anchors goop on
him right there
I just think that all these guys are you
know big shots until like you know even
Robin I'd like to see you go out in
front of a whole crowd not that you said
you could do it but like everybody's a
big shot when they're on the air at a
recent Chicago White Sox game an
employee at the ballpark was given a
chance to throw out the first pitch she
accidentally hit a cameraman right in
front of her of course Gary's pitch was
mentioned in this story watch it one
more time the wrong way releases just a
little bit late it doesn't look that bad
Howard Stern's producer Gary Dell'Abate
back then hey he threw one that was one
for the ages too just been awful he
practiced and practice and under
pressure I mean that'll be part of your
obituary when you die the world
shittiest picture well don't you believe
it would be in his obituary I'm not sure
I think it would be people would feel
bad enough to keep it out of it though
but to say it is a fun thing like hey
you know Howard Stern's longtime
producer Gary bababooey Dell'Abate known
for not only his work on the radio but
also for his legendary bad pitch when he
threw out the first pitch at a Mets game
yeah I think it will could you die Gary
so we can say oh and it'll be like
people who throw horrible pitches across
America in his honor are called the
bobble buoys like there might even be a
cult my Met was telling me he really
thinks Gary should throw the first pitch
what your office is pulling for him
honestly it would be the funnest coolest
thing ever if Gary did it are you saying
it because you want to see him fail or
you say that would be great that would
be funny but I would also like to see
him succeed too I think it would be cool
I think would be great for this would be
big what do you think he should do so he
shouldn't do it again really yeah
because I think he's gonna do it really
really well and then he's gonna just
brag about and gloat that he did it well
and he made a mistake I think he should
definitely not do it
but you [ __ ] up as you succeeding
this is so much fun that Gary [ __ ] it
up that right did it well then it would
dissipate like when you see a clown as
those at a circus if it doesn't [ __ ] up
and fall down and slip you're not
laughing right but I don't think anybody
will ever remember Gary throwing a good
pitch
I agree Robin but the thing is Gary Gary
Howard just said that and now to say oh
I could do it Gary said that four years
before this pitch you said that he was
acting like a big shot before his first
day yeah yeah that's what Gary fails to
realize you said it Gary you said you
could do it you said I threw like a girl
and Jason threw like a girl and we were
incompetent right and then you went out
there and made the biggest [ __ ] out
of yourself like he used to goof on the
way you threw yes I think I could pitch
better than Gary and I've never thrown a
ball in my life to Shea to me to myself
so you're saying Gary no longer can be
bragging in the halls how he's so great
at all not only do you a field which was
a tremendous amount of pressure okay
I'll give him that much
then jimmy kimmel a small little studio
right what does he hit he hits a lady
out of all people I mean in the head
yeah there was a giant stage there he
could have went over them
he hit a poor helpless lady in the head
she knows we're near Jimmy Kimmel she
was in Wisconsin is now weighing